Це район Шанхай.
Ми називаємо це Чін-Тікі або Китай-город.
Колись наш регіон вважався таким дуже багатим,
сюди всі їхали там на якийсь базар, ще щось,
бо в шахтарів завжди були гроші.
Треба вирости в шахтарському місті,
щоб зрозуміти чому це печально.
Хоча справа звісно класна, але творчості
точно ніякої не спостерігається в такій сфері діяльності.
А коли ти людина творча, то хочеться
докладати кудись зусилля,
і свій час витрачати точно
не добуваючи вугілля.
Хтось має вугілля копати,
а хтось має бонги робити.
Так склалося, що в певний момент ми
об'єдналися навколо цієї ідеї — видувати скло.
Почали буквально з того, що у нас
нічого не було, була тільки ідея.
Нас є п'ятеро людей в команді.
Між собою ще не всі були знайомі навіть.
Моя роль була продати свій автомобіль
і вкласти у це все кошти.
Що я, в принципі, і зробив.
На той момент в мене була можливість,
я нею скористався, і не шкодував анітрохи.
Ось наша остання робота,
вона називається Recycle Bong.
Він повністю задутий сріблом,
техніка називається «ф'юмінг».
Це нанесення дорогоцінних металів на скло.
Завдяки цьому, коли виріб
стає брудним всередині...
Зазвичай вони після експлуатації
робляться чорними і некрасивими.
Ці вироби будуть змінювати свій колір,
вони будуть проявлятися,
і колір ставатиме синьо-фіолетовим.
Це перший в Україні такий зроблений.
Є такий термін «heady pipes»,
в Америці він присутній.
Це ось такі дивакуваті вироби, які закладають в собі
певну естетику, якийсь зміст, певну форму, або ще щось.
І це є саме функціональне скло,
тобто можна покурити.
До цього студія функціонувала 3 роки,
аби ми могли вийти на цей рівень.
Починали ми зі звичайних люльок,
прозорих, нецікавих.
Тільки у нас була фішка в тому,
що вони були дуже міцні.
Ось така люлька від удару абсолютно не тріскає.
І вони не нагріваються, це такий
плюс навіть у прозорих.
З хлопцями мали практику:
переклали фільм про мистецтво glass blowing'у.
Є фільм, який називається «Дегеренативне мистецтво»,
який ми продублювали своїми голосами в студії.
Там розповідається про історію,
про засновників, як мистецтво розвивалося,
тому що воно сприймалося
як нелегальне в Америці.
Це саме про люльки і баблери.
Але через американські суди
люди відстояли свої права,
що це просто вид мистецтва і все,
і нічого страшного в тому немає.
Хоча важкі і легкі наркотики ми теж
не вживаємо — нікому не рекомендуємо.
Справа у вогні —
є різні температурні режими.
Є різний вогонь: є м'який, є кисневий,
який дуже сильний для скла.
Кожне скло по-різному реагує
на температуру вогню.
Коли тільки починаєш цим займатися,
дуже багато часу витрачається на те,
щоб зрозуміти фізику скла.
Я тримаю руку буквально за 10 см від вогню,
а скло там вже холодне.
А ось тут в полум'ї десь
1000-1100 градусів, і скло тече.
Тобто якщо я перестану зараз його крутити,
то воно попливе і впаде вниз.
Трошки такий процес медитативний,
і потрібен час на це, тому що
інакше ніяк.
Чим більше часу присвячуєш для виробу,
тим більше в нього вкладаєш,
тим кращий він виходить.
Акуратніший і з душею.